in favor of Ukraine being independent
democratic and well reliable partner for
both the united states and the united
Europe so this is to the best of my
knowledge the position of the United
States as to pray and it won't impair
the position of the United States under
different administrations and the
position of the European Union I will
say that the United States policy
towards Ukraine was much more European
than the position of the European Union
towards Ukraine or some European
countries so I'm talking about the
periods that if you'll make the first
the perhaps the position will change at
least we do home some people say that
the United States are interested in
pushing he praying of the Russia's
domination I don't believe in this
assertions simply if one analyzed the
policy of the United States recently in
well the former Soviet Union one may
notice
the united states are trying to to
consolidate the establishment to
consolidate their presence so which is
not to the liking of russia and despite
all this the united states are pursuing
their interest in the former Soviet
Union so and the two to push Ukraine
closer to Russia with the would be wrong
and ill-prepared policy part of the
United States administration I do
remember the worst time when at the
beginning of autumn 1991 immediately
after ukrainian parliament has
proclaimed its independence there was
there was a serious debate within the US
administration of them President Bush
Senior as to whether to recognize
independence of Ukraine and I remember
that as a result of this debate well the
parts of the administration will one
leading by the State Department we're
against recognition
brain and the Department of Defense were
in favor of recognition with Ukraine
then had it by current vice president
cheney and frankly the result was
positive but for this the interference
of the White House National Security
Council was me so I don't believe the
United States will the push Ukraine
closer under the domination over by the
head to keep in mind that the American
pointing toward the former Union
countries very much conservative means
that Americans america american
politicians they will not die i'm going
to return of course for independent
independence of the of the process of it
union states it's after these states to
be at least half a step ahead because if
not the Americans will always address
the same policy
muscle
don't I would say 10 Putin's election is
closed in ohio and michigan is knowing
how US foreign policy is formulated and
that's very useful in keeping their
attention on and but a general term I
wonder if you could both speak more
about 9 11 at the time 911 pain we all
fought Washington be oriented to another
policy it was going to interested in the
Central Europe what I got in to resume
each piece thought was this recasting of
this southeast vector in a way of
placing it now in America's global
interest interested in in dis belt about
stability stability but more generally
if you
what you know what have you seen going
on has the was there a period when
Washington became less interesting and
now has been now this has once again
again how much that relate to their view
degree but how much was also relating to
this is instabilities on
all right I think